eq nos députés européens montrent des
républicains on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour oriane bon genre de choses on
commence par la crise sanitaire
évidemment brice hortefeux et jean
castex qui prendra donc la parole ce
soir il ne devrait pas annoncer de
nouvelles mesures restrictives a priori
est ce que vous dites que le
gouvernement a raison de miser sur la
responsabilité plutôt que sur la
contrainte
en tout cas ce que j'observe c'est que
le président de la république et le
gouvernement ont une ligne constante
c'est être fort tard ils sont en retard
systématiquement sur tout mais on a été
en retard sur les masques et pour dire
une raison vous connaissez puisque je
vous rappelle qu'ils avaient 754
millions de masques en 2017 et au moment
de la crise y en avait plus de cent
demandent donc en retard sur les masques
en retard sur les tests en retard sur le
visionnement en retard sur la fermeture
des frontières en retard sur les vaccins
en retard sur caen finale en retard sur
l'ensemble d'une politique de la
politique sanitaire la marque de
fabrique de ce goût d'amande ou ce
gouvernement et du président de la
république c'est d'être systématiquement
en retard par rapport à l'événement par
rapport à l'actualité
maintenant la question si la question
c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on finisse pas
moi je n'ai pas les éléments techniques
et puisque on nous les communiquent pas
très très clairement faudrait faut le
reconnaître
j'observe qu'il n'ya plus aujourd'hui
que quatre ou cinq pays qui sont
confinés donc il faut observer aussi ce
qui se passe à l'étranger ce qui ne
s'est pas fait du tout là aussi où début
de cette crise puisque l'on est et on
faisait du nombrilisme me regardez pas
où comment ça marche et ailleurs un mot
sur une décision qui concerne votre
région vers rhône-alpes c'est le choix
du gouvernement de ne pas rouvrir les
remontées mécaniques c'est une saison
blanche qui s'annonce pour les stations
de ski est ce que vous comprenez cette
décision c'est une décision que j'ai
nettement du mal à comprendre et
d'ailleurs avec laurent wauquiez le
président du conseil régional
qui s'était placé nous quasiment dans
toutes les principales stations en tout
cas bassin de deux montagnes de la
région et nous étions c'est la fin de la
semaine dernière avec le sénateur jean
marc boyer nous étions au mont d'or qui
naissaient qui représentative des
stations de moyenne montagne
on a participé à cette rencontre avec
l'ensemble des acteurs qui sont
totalement pris à la gorge
donc est ce que c'est une mesure et qui
est justifié et jeunes moi je n'en suis
pas convaincu
je pense que dès lors que l'on peut
aller faire ses courses dans un
supermarché
dès lors que les établissements sont
ouverts je ne comprends pas bien
pourquoi on ne peut pas descendre une
piste
le gouvernement a mis 4 milliards sur la
table pour aider pour aider les stations
de ski et qu'est ce que vous disent les
preuves les professionnels disent que ça
va se suffire selon eux au moins à
passer le cap de cette crise oui le
principe est justifiée c'est la moindre
des choses puisqu'on les interdits on
leur interdit de travailler nos j'ai eu
aussi des remontées selon lesquelles le
versement se fait pas aussi rapidement
j'ai notamment le cas d'une personne qui
devaient être indemnisées pas au mont
d'or dont dans le bassin bassin du
massif du sancy en auvergne qu'il avait
aperçu une indemnisation en novembre
mais qui n'avait rien perçu depuis
c'était vous étions donc le week end
dernier tous deux presque déjà au début
du mois de février
donc il y a aussi des lourdeurs
administratives contestable le mans qui
les retards aussi sur les aides en plus
des retards que vous plantiez tout à le
mecque oui mais j'ai choisi surtout sur
la crise sanitaire il ya ces éléments là
il restait deux sectoriel les
collectivités locales
d'ailleurs heureusement accompagne mais
il n'y a pas il doit pas y avoir dans
mon esprit d'ambiguïté la politique
sanitaire c'est une politique
régaliennes cela relève de l'état et
l'ère laurent wauquiez lui à une
position qui est une position
extrêmement saine c'est de dire que les
collectivités sont là non pas pour
remplacer pourra se lancer leur propre
initiative 60 sont à pois aider pour
accompagner pour compléter la politique
régaliennes qui relève de l'état pas
nous ne sommes pas dans une république
fédérale regarder ce qui se passe en
allemagne regarder ce qui se passe en
espagne
les collecter la population ne comprend
rien à la politique sanitaire qui est
menée non nous nous sommes la république
française la politique sanitaire c'est
l'état les collectivités locales peuvent
imaginer et des seconds et accompagner
il doit pas y avoir de confusion des
genres alors ceci dit à l'arrivée vous
voyez le désastre c'est que on est à un
million six de personnes vaccinées qu au
moment où l'allemagne est à 2000 en 6 ou
israël et à 5 millions ou le royaume uni
est large et à 10 millions les
etats-unis sont à 32 millions justement
monsieur ferrals le désastre ans on va
parler politique vaccinale vous êtes
député européen et aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que des voix s'élèvent pour
critiquer la stratégie européenne autour
de 7,2 cette question la présidente
ursula von der leyen elle même a été
pointé sur des erreurs fondamentales
est-ce que vous souscrivez ou fait que
justement on a été on n'a pas été au
point en europe la politique européenne
et française puisque la france la france
a validé ce qui est saisie c'est yves
haupert il faut éviter quand même d'être
trop schématique et d'être caricatural
et peut-être même injuste il y a deux
éléments dans ce cas initié l'europe il
y a deux aspects qui sont des aspects
incontestablement positif l'euro va
jouer un rôle positif 1 sur la sûreté
sanitaire est d'ailleurs la président de
la commission l'a longuement expliquée
notamment par comparaison à ce qui se
passait au royaume-uni alors il y avait
tout ça bien sûr et des arrière pensées
mais c'est vrai qu'on a
l'europe a fait le choix de la sûreté
sanitaire donc c'est un petit peu plus
lent et deuxième élément le
le fait que l'europe se soient regroupés
un certain certainement jouer sur les
prix ne pense pas me tromper mais en
rappelant que lorsque on s'interrogeait
sur les prix au départ- vaccin tout au
début sa tournée entre 24 rendu à 24,30
euros bon de même un peu plus avérée et
là on a des la moyenne des vaccins ses 7
à 14 euros donc on peut considérer que
l'europe a joint le point sur ces deux
points sur sécurité sanitaire et
précieux s'est vengé sécurité sanitaire
justement certains ont critiqué le fait
que l'agencé européenne des médicaments
prennent beaucoup de temps
on regarde du fait que d'autres agences
nationales tmz des rues du royaume uni
ou celle des états unis aurait très bien
pu au regard des standards en voit entre
entre les deux pour voir être validée
plus rapidement par par par l'europe en
fait est ce qu'on n'a pas manqué
finalement de coordination même entre
l'europe et d'autres pays qui finalement
ont validé dès des vaccins beaucoup plus
rapidement que nous avec les mêmes
standards mais ça c'est c'est très
exactement ma conviction dans ce domaine
comme dans les autres c'est qu'on ne
souffre pas d'un excès d'europe et d'un
déficit
c'est une différence que j'ai avec un
certain nombre d'amis compris est
familier politique je pense que l'europe
dans ce domaine a été utile sur ces deux
points mais que le retard qui a été pris
parce que le retard est bien réel vient
du fait que sans doute on n'y avait pas
eu assez de coordination est l'exemple
des agences de santé est certainement le
plus révélateur dans cette période mais
il n'y a pas de responsabilité d'ursula
von der leyen pour vous cheese et la
machine européenne qui veut ça c'est
elle qui a commis des erreurs dans sa
stratégie par définition
la responsable s'est enfin le ou la
responsable est celui qui est à la tête
ou celle qui est à la tête donc oui il y
a une responsabilité de la commission et
de la présidente de la commission sur ce
point mais c'est incontestable mais
intégrant bien le fait qu' il y avait
deux double choix qui avait été fait
vous parlez est là c'est que vous parlez
du royaume uni justement qui s'en sort
bien en tout cas en termes de
vaccination vous le dit hein ça
vaccinale à tour de bras beaucoup plus
que chez nous est-ce que du coup ça
donne pas l'impression qu'il vaut mieux
être hors de l'union européenne
pourraient sur sa stratégie de
vaccination est ce que c'est pas risqué
pour les pro européens
oui c'est risqué de enfin je vous
rencontre fois je rappelle le chiffre
c'est 1 million 600 mille vaccinées en
france plus de 10 millions au royaume
uni le dock ou si vous prenez des états
les collections d'israël a été largement
commentée non c'est pas c'est pas en
europe enfin c'est l'exemple d'un état
mais ils y répondent a man mais c'est ce
qu'ont fait les autres pays ont fait un
choix c'est de payer le plus cher sur
lorsque du monde et ce qu'il fallait
mégoter sur le prix est en tout cas fait
pas mégoté sur la sécurité sanitaire
je pense que la thur l'europe a eu a eu
raison bien sûr mais vous avez raison
et j'observe avec une certaine
inquiétude que par exemple la hongrie
est en train de discuter pour
directement sans passer par le
structures communautaires rejet à dire
c'est ça il ya quelques semaines il
disait il faut que la france passe hors
de l'union européenne à n'importe quel
prix pour commander des vaccins vous
êtes d'accord avec ça je pense que je
pense que la priorité des priorités
c'est d'assurer la sécurité sanitaire à
la protection de nos compatriotes mais
sans passer par les longues et moi je
dis il faut être pragmatique faut pas
être idéologie idéologues sur ce point
si on peut aller plus vite en passant
avec les la communauté européenne mais
aussi en négociant directement il mais
il faut utiliser ce chemin de contourner
l'union européenne ne va qu il faut
avoir une ligne la ligne c'est la
protection maximale de nos compatriotes
voilà la gym de emmanuel macron sait on
passe par l'union européenne on est plus
forts à 27 pour vous c'est pas la bonne
ligne il fonda il s'interdire on a été
plus fort à 27 sur les prix et sur la
sécurité on est moins forts à 27 sur la
rapidité de la vaccination
il faut le reconnaître le fait que
certaines régions aussi réclament à
faire des passes et des commandes elle
même temps vous et c'est quoi c'est joli
je crois que je vous ai répondu la
politique sanitaire c'est une politique
régaliennes à parler du national en ce
moment oui lourd dossier qui qui je
pense en tant qu'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur vous intéressera
particulièrement est ce que c'est un
projet de loi que les républicains votre
famille politique aurait pu faire comme
quand on était en responsabilité quand
les français de les confier la majorité
inutile de vous dire qu on en a fait
bien sûr bon et on l'a fait sur
plusieurs point barre de m'interroger
sur lequel on ce projet de loi sur ce
projet là aussi juge va par tempérament
j'aime pas être schématique et
caricatural donc c'est pas parce que le
gouvernement le fait que c'est bien ou
systématiquement bien ou
systématiquement mal
alors je vais regarder le texte je pense
très sincèrement que tout n'est pas
inutile mais il n'ya rien d'essentiel
tout n'est pas inutile parce que des
bonnes mesures sur le la clarté sur le
financement sur une mesure qui était une
très bonne mesure qui est la possibilité
pour les préfets d'agir très directement
de manière à être réactif avant de les
référer pour les déférer comme s'il y a
des quand il constate des dérives si tu
ça c'est une bonne mesure mais en
revanche il n'y
il n'ya rien d'essentiel c'est à dire
que cela a été dit à juste titre rien
sur la question migratoire écoutait des
considéré qu' il y avait une fois de
lier un moment ça a peut bien sûr avoir
oublié cette question des jeunes et non
pas une amp aux billets ils ont écarté
je pense pas une seconde que c'est pas
inadvertance c'est l'élan ils l'ont
écarté parce que sans nous avait un peu
peur il n'y a rien sur le donc sur
l'immigration peut-être qu'on peut en
dire un mot puisque les derniers
chiffres ont été rendus publics il ya
quelques heures quelques à peine
quelques jours il n'y a rien sur le
terrorisme et il n'y a rien pour être
plus précis sur le voile des
accompagnant des sorties scolaires
il n'ya rien où il refuse qu'il y ait
quelque chose sur le voile à
l'université fudan je m'arrête juste une
seconde il me permettez sur ce point le
voilà une université je pense que c'est
une erreur grave
je vous explique pourquoi aujourd'hui la
question du voile à l'université ça
concerne quasiment à personne conscient
de la lui disons en gros 15 cas annuels
où il ya une difficulté une tension voit
donc aujourd'hui si on décide c'est pas
un drame
voilà qu'on dise c'est comme ça on le
décide c'est interdit il ya d'autres
pays qui l'ont fait il ya des pays dans
lequel il y a deux
mais mesure en belgique par exemple les
voisins où il y avait autrefois dans des
pays arabes comme la tunisie qui
l'interdisait quoi donc aujourd'hui ça
serait pas un drame
on attend on ne fait rien on ne met sous
le tapis d'ici quelques peu de temps ça
sera quelques dizaines et ensuite on ira
quelques centaines y on aboutira à le
voile à l'université
ensuite on passera à le sport enfin les
piscines dans le cadre du sport pas de
mixité ensuite ça sera dans le sport en
général et ensuite on arrive on
travaille en binôme
c'est joli c'est écrit c'est inéluctable
pourquoi ne pas profiter du fait que
aujourd'hui cela consciente que très peu
de cas pour prendre une mesure qui soit
une mesure claire simple et qui ne
serait pas contesté pourquoi être
toujours en retard
mais est-ce pour vous en faites le voile
à l'université où le voile n'est donc
des jeunes et des étudiantes est
finalement mène au bout du bout à une
islamisation de la société
mais bien sûr dès lors que l'on cède sur
la laïcité
l'espace est immédiatement occupé et
aujourd'hui il est occupé par une forme
de de militantisme islamique qui peut
aboutir à des ré ça n'aboutit pas
heureusement à chaque fois à des dérives
dangereuses mais c'est comme ça c'est
moi j'étais comme j'imagine comme vous
frapper dans le milieu scolaire
à l'issue de la minute de silence mais
la mémoire d'enseignant c'est mieux
pâtit on a recensé mission d'éducation
nationale a recensé 793 problème trouble
s'est beaucoup réduit censé beaucoup ça
veut dire qu'il ya quelque chose auquel
il faut être extrêmement vigilant c'est
un signal extrêmement fort
quand vous avez dans le même temps 42 %
des enseignants qui s'autocensurent dès
lors qu'ils doivent aborder les
questions de l'enseignement historique
des religions 42% qui on ne va pas y
aller
on ne va pas expliquer on ne va pas
enseigner parce que on craint qu'il y
ait un retour dessus va ce sont des
signaux qui montrent qu'il faut agir et
qu'il faut agir vite
ce ce projet de loi donc ne répond pas
assez à ces questions selon vous vous
parlez aussi de du lien qui n'est pas
fait avec l'immigration est ce que
concrètement vous dénoncez l'heure
actuelle une politique migratoire
insuffisante
bien sûr on avait atteint vous le savez
depuis ces trois dernières années des
chiffres historiquement haut de
migration dans notre pays annuel puisque
la réalité et malgré d'ailleurs le coc
vide c'est que l'on terminera le
quinquennat macron ça sera en fête et je
suis sûr de ne pas me tromper
autour d'un million 800 mille migrants
supplémentaires c'est-à-dire c'est plus
important que toute la ville de
marseille toute la ville de lyon c'est
presque la ville de paris j ai pu le coi
vie serait était d'ailleurs plus
important que la ville de paris donc
qu'il y à un afflux migratoires dont
nous n'avons ni le besoin ni la capacité
de tous les titres de simples ce titre
de séjour dont les titres de séjour
excusez moi monsieur feu les titres de
séjour ont augmenté de 2 2% entre 2017
et 2019
c'est une réalité c'est la même
proportion qui agitait le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy
le 2007 à 2009 il ya eu exactement la
même la même augmentation
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas qu'une vue
qu'un simple effet pas du tout c'est une
chose que vous dites et est inexact
parce que ce qui vous utilisez les avons
évoqué des pourcentages mais vous
qui par les chiffres les chiffres sont
un réel vous avez eu 270 mille titres de
séjour
l'un des derniers acquis ont été
délivrés ça ne s'est pas vu depuis 43
ans
donc je vous parle pas de simplement
nicolas sarkozy je veux pas vu depuis 43
ans
donc ce qui est exact c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y à une baisse du fait
du coc vide
puisqu'on est passé de 210 à 220
non c'est pas exactement ça qu il faut
que vous comptiez aussi les demandeurs
d'asile puisque sont tes titres de
séjour légaux en quelque sorte pas donc
vous avez l'an 2000 les 19 vous aviez
415 mille de m'arriver légal et cette
année c'est tombé cette année en 2020
puis que les chiffres sont connus depuis
quelques heures
ils ont des tombées à 3 102 milles dont
vous avez effectivement une baisse mais
cette baisse est liée à la crise
sanitaire
et d'ailleurs je vous fait observer que
dans le même temps les reconduit des
illégaux ont baissé ça on n'en parle pas
je ne sais pas pourquoi ont baissé de
moitié à s'embêter de 50% qu'on est
passé de 31 mille reconduites en 2010 9
à 15 milles en 2020 ces deux-là la crise
sanitaire il faut le savoir aussi mais
si jusque là christianites et c'est
pourquoi je vous dis ça tout simplement
parce que quand cette crise sanitaire
quand on va en sortir il va y avoir
naturellement un rattrapage extrêmement
violent parce que les pays sont tous
touchés par cette crise sanitaire dont
qui va y avoir des difficultés
économiques dans les pays sources qu'ils
vont encourager encore plus à venir sur
notre territoire
donc il faut s'y préparer et là je
n'entends pas un mot sur ce sujet il n'y
a aucune préparation sur ce qui va se
produire dès la sortie de cette crise a
dit on va dire un mot du bureau de la
sécurité puisque julien une rappelez
vous êtes ancien ministre de l'intérieur
à bourg de la sécurité qui a commencé
lundi qui vise à renforcer le lien entre
police et population à renforcer les
moyens des forces de l'ordre à répondre
aux sept péchés capitaux listés par
gérald darmanin est ce que vous dites
c'est la bonne méthode vous d'été
organisés des tableaux je crois qu'il y
en a huit qui sont
aurait vu ça c'est fait ça se fait
aujourd'hui ça se fera certainement
demain c'est une option
j'observe de choses on va voir si c'est
utile
j'observe de choses c'est que d'abord
les syndicats de policiers qui vous
savez sont extrêmement représentatif la
taux de syndicalisation dans la société
7-6 a vu pensant dans la police et 80 %
pape lui même le 80%
j'observe que les deux principaux
syndicats c'est à dire alliance sgp fo
ont exprimé un très grand scepticisme
sur le sujet et j'observe aussi
parallèlement qu' il y a une réserve
notamment des chercheurs qui regrette
que l'on ne profite pas de cette
occasion pour engager une réflexion sur
long terme sur l'avenir des forces de
police et surtout effectivement des
rapports entre la police et la société
donc ce sont deux points qui sont un
petit peu qui souligne un certain manque
mais on sera on jugera à l'arrivée parce
que s'il faut ça débouche sur quelque
chose ce que ce que je ne souhaite pas
c'est que ce beauvau la sécurité soit à
anna libye pour faire patienter
ça ça serait une erreur et on le
redoutait oui oui
il ya beaucoup d'échéances là qui vont
qui vont agiter votre votre famille on
les régionales évidemment mais est ce
que au delà pour la présidentielle est
ce que vous pouvez vous nous dire si
vous êtes favorable à la primaire je
suis favorable d'abord à ce qu'il y est
un candidat issu de notre famille
politique quand une famille politique ne
présente pas de candidats à l'élection
majeure à la vocation à disparaître elle
n'a pas d'utilité en vérité moi donc je
suis favorable à ce qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui soit issu de notre famille
politique famille au sens large
vous comptez les cousins vous montez la
famille très proche car le principe
c'est aux lèvres je préfère mes enfants
mes neveux mes neveux à mes cousins mes
cousins sur le plateau est donc voilà
donc
donc ça veut dire que xavier bertrand
peut-il être un candidat pour la droite
c'est pas jojo ne personnalise pas à ce
niveau là
bon j'observe premiers éléments la
première question c'est est ce qu'il ya
un candidat naturel
en vérité de candidat naturel c'est ça
rien de se cacher derrière son pouce il
n'y a que deux qui était possible d'y
colas sarkozy et françois baroin hélas
ni l'autre à ce stade on a des
indiqué leur appétence pour vous le
regrettez donc à perdre bien sûr je
regrette donc ya pas de candidat naturel
il y à des prétendants comme il n'y a
pas de candidat naturel faudra imaginer
naturellement un système pour les
départager c'est ce à quoi s'attelle le
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
consul qui m'a reçu moi je les remets au
cir note pour pour donner des pistes
puis l'embauché il en fera ce qu'il
voudra et nous en font avec d'autres
propositions on examinera mais on était
la situation vous voulez la présenter
comme compliquée elle est très simple
candidat naturel n'y a pas de départage
comme il n'y a pas de candidat naturel
il faudra très certainement un système
de départage mais d'ici là il y aura eu
les élections régionales sera permis
aussi certainement d'y voir un peu plus
clair d'éclairer mais c'est un policier
le dernier ça serait un bon candidat
mais nous avons la chance s'ils
voulaient d'avoir effectivement beaucoup
de personnalités qui sont des
personnalités michel barnier a une
expérience elle longue et les sérieux il
est méthodique il avait montré qu'il ce
qu'il savait faire
vous avez valérie pécresse qui
présidente de la région ile de france
vous avez leur nous avons beaucoup de
candidats qui sont des candidats qui
pour finir puisque sur votre région et
sur cette phrase de jean castex sur
cette phrase de jean castex à colmar qui
a fustigé finalement la création de ces
grandes régions dont la région vers le
rhône alpes fait partie vous êtes
d'accord avec le premier ministre
comment il avait entendu cette phrase et
moi jean castex
je partage sur cent d'opinions ou shawn
et dans quelles conditions ces réformes
sont faites à 18h30 on ne savait pas qui
était le découpage dans la nuit les
journaux de honte écrit qu'ils allaient
avoir un découpage où il n'avait pas il
donc le lendemain matin ou ou
tardivement dans la nuit c'était ni fait
ni à faire
et j'observe pour pour l'exemple qu'elle
bien j'étais vice-président la région
viendront d'alger heureusement que
laurent wauquiez et aider des élus
régionaux parce que c'est pas un travail
personnel cintra et collectifs mais
notamment des élus régionaux auvergnats
nous sommes mobilisés parce que quand
vous avez une région qui fait 6 millions
d'habitants et notre région qui faisait
un million trois cent mille habitants
bien évidemment le partenariat est un
peu déséquilibré donc on voit bien que
là en l'occurrence l'ovale louis était
bénéficiaire mais les bénéficiaires
parce qu'ils la volonté humaine de
protéger le territoire auvergnat et on
reste comme ça où il faut revoir
maintenant c'est qu'en deux régions moi
je pense qu'on aurait dû consulter
enfin à l'époque on a consulté président
en personne bon là consulter 14
parlementaires auvergnats brand vieux
pardon en paca dont les a consultés
parce qu'ils avaient des votes bon
c'était pas suffisant ce n'était pas la
bonne méthode ça redécoupage qui a sauvé
les départements sont oui bien sûr mais
surtout dire que on est arrivé avec une
idée régionaliste et puis à l'arrivée il
vient en plus les régions sont grandes
plus limité et
elle est donc les départements au
trouvent une utilité un dernier mot
rapidement puisqu'on a plutôt temps luc
hervé kivu précédé dit qu'il est
favorable à une fusion de la savoie et
de la haute-savoie pour faire une
collectivité sur le modèle de la
collectivité d'alsace vous êtes somme
râble c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
une piste enfin encore une fois ça doit
passer par la consultation de la
population ça doit être la méthode et
vers l' inverse de ce qui a été accompli
sous la présidence hollande dans le
cadre de ces fusions de région et vous
savez combien par exemple dans le grand
est a été traumatisant vous quel est
votre avis là dessus sur la fission
savoie de ça va coûter moi je suis
auvergnat désert juste eu suffisamment
de sujets comme cela merci beaucoup
merci sorte fait d'avoir été notre
invité merci julien on regarde la une de
la voix du nord sur les vaccins la
france à un tournant c'est à lire ce
matin dans la voix du nord en pas de
sitôt cloud et à être ici la mutuelle
nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vaud présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]